we know a lot of you are looking for
jobs right now and with that in mind
there are a lot of job
fairs happening the cosmopolitan holding
a hiring event tomorrow from 10 until
two at the chelsea
looking for cooks food servers guest
room attendance and more
you can apply online first by going to
cosmopolitanlasvegas.com
mgm resorts holding hiring events
tomorrow through thursday at the
mandalay bay convention center
the company looking for guest room
attendants security officers pool jobs
and front desk employees
and security company allied universal
also hiring there's again a lot of
companies are hiring now they need staff
they're celebrating military
appreciation month and holding military
monday hiring events
there's one today from 1 30 to 3 near
eastern flamingo
in-person and virtual interviews are
available for you encouraged applicants
should go online first
as i mentioned there are a lot of
companies that are hiring right now
there is a shortage in the workforce
we have a list of the companies hiring
at 8newsnow.com
just click on the job board tab